most estimates seem to say that we're a
week to ten days away from the peak of
the virus does the NHS have enough
capacity to deal with that pink I think
that indeed we are we are just that a
week away from from the surge of this
we've been preparing really really hard
to to manage that surgeon to manage that
real increase in demand we are already
seeing hospitals and other types of
health care providers really facing the
pressure on this but I think so far they
are managing okay but I think the things
that we need to remember are that we
need to really focus on on protective
equipment we really need to focus on
testing and we really need to focus on
ventilator capacity so if we just take
protective equipment because that's been
such a highlight of of the conversations
that we've heard about the health
service over the last week to two weeks
and there's real lack of confidence of
frontline staff and also hospital and
other Health Service chief executives
about about whether they are adequate
and whether we've got the supply and I
think that the changing guidance that we
saw earlier this week should really give
us that confidence and we are hoping
that it does give us that confidence but
what that needs to be backed up with is
the confidence of supply and I'm not
sure we're there yet we've seen really
huge transformation in the supply chain
if you cast back four weeks or so there
was a 500% increase over a 72-hour
period for demand for all of this
protective equipment we know it's
getting better we hear far less from our
trust chief executives about you know
shortages but those shortages are still
there right now we know there's a real
shortage of shortage of gowns there's a
shortage of visors so we need to see
that turned around as quickly as
possible but I have to to pay tribute
both to staff on the frontline trust
chief executives and also those who are
working with the center to manage the
supply chain because they've done
something in
over the last few weeks to try and get a
system in place that will work but this
is unprecedented demand so you know we
are really grappling with real-time
changes so that's the protective
equipment and it's absolutely critical
that we sort that out and give
confidence of supply as well as called
okay in the protection there's some
improvements but more to be done in
other areas as well testing is another
thing of course that's been really
focused on - and that Hankook saying
that they want to ramp up to a hundred
thousand tests a day but of course we're
only around 10,000 now are you is it
doable do you think to increase capacity
so much over time this may be doable but
I think what we've got to be clear about
is that the government needs to talk
really closely and work really closely
with the frontline in delivering this
ramp up of testing so at the moment so
we're talking about a hundred thousand a
day by the end of April at the moment
we're probably somewhere around 13,000 a
day trusts on the front line really want
to play their part in this and they can
play their part in this we're not yet
clear if the supply of raw materials
such as swabs and the reagents that's
needed is gonna be as smooth as we would
like it to be but the critical point
around testing is the fact that this is
about vacancies on the frontline the
more staff we test the more stuff we can
get back to work because obviously we
have staff who are self isolating at the
moment because they're in households
where someone else is unwell possibly
with coronavirus with or possibly with
something else but we really need to get
staff back to work because without that
you know then we can't run the health
service effectively and I if I can just
wait make one point this isn't just
about hospital staff this is about staff
out in the community doing home visits
this is about mental health trust staff
who are supporting people in an
inpatient setting so it's it's all types
of stuff and our paramedics as well so
ok this is out ramping up that testing
now you also mentioned ventilators on
your first answer as well and my
question to you as well is
how worried are you about any regional
disparity because we know that there's
been peaks occurring at different stages
around the country London the West
Midlands for example hit much worse are
you concerned that some NHS trusts may
be better prepared than others in
dealing with what is to come well we
know that the the stock of ventilate is
ventilated is being managed nationally
so that's really important to remember
so the supply will come through national
routes I think that the nature of this
pandemic is that it has is spreading
from region to region London is probably
best prepared because London has seen
the kind of surge in demand hitting
first but it's absolutely critical but
we make sure that every part of the
country is supported okay if a massive
transformation that we are seeing in in
our usual Hospital services to set up
their own mini nightingales on their
patch is absolutely astonishing and I
think the one way that the country could
pay tribute to all of the work that has
been done is is to stay at home indoors
in this really sunny weather so then all
that the points on that point about
staying indoors are in the sunny weather
what would you say to people what's your
message to those who may be tempted to
break the lock down so our chief
executive chris Hopson put it really
well yesterday when he said it's one
thing to stand outside your front door
and clap for the NHS health and care
staff please carry on doing that it's
immensely motivating but the biggest
step you could take would be to make
sure that you stay at home because we
need to stop the spread of the virus we
can treat people but surely it's better
to stop people getting it in the first
place